[Applause]
europe's largest economy will be
expecting a lot from angela merkel's
successor
so
what's on the to-do list
[Music]
climate change has played a bigger role
in germany's election than it might have
done in other years or in other
developed countries that in part is
because of the huge destruction caused
by flooding a couple of months ago
they killed nearly 200 people and left
many missing
[Music]
but it's not just about floods a
citizens assembly of 160 people was
commissioned to advise on what climate
ambitions germany should incorporate
into its public policy
the assembly backed plans for a coal
phase-out by 2030 a ban on internal
combustion car engines by the same year
and compulsory installation of solar
panels on new buildings
most germans believe the country and the
eu are simply not doing enough on
climate protection but implementing
those new climate policies will have a
big impact for instance germany still
leans heavily on coal to power its
world-famous factories
this won't be easy for the new
chancellor
germany has played a key leadership role
in the eu so maintaining and shaping
that sense of european unity will be
crucial for the next chancellor but
germans are beginning to have doubts the
eu's vaccination program was slow to get
going and one recent study found that a
striking 55 of germans believe the eu's
political system is broken
that figures up by a quarter from just
12 months before
there have been tensions between the
northern and southern european countries
about who should be paying for europe's
post-pandemic reconstruction the new
chancellor will need to help calm those
strained tempers and at home
a familiar challenge
immigration remains a big issue for some
voters
merkel allowed in many many migrants the
new chancellor will have their own views
since 2015 china has become germany's
largest trading partner goods worth
nearly 213 billion euros were traded
between the two countries in
but the us's increasingly hostile
attitude towards china has put pressure
on germany's close relationship so far
it's refused to cease its booming trade
and under merkel it opted for the
concept of vandal de grandel or change
through trade
um
actually
[Music]
[Music]
as other countries criticize the
detention of weaker muslims and the
imposition of draconian security laws in
hong kong berlin remained largely silent
but that approach is becoming much
harder to defend
a poll in august found that 58 of
respondents wanted the government to
take a harder line against beijing to
defend its own interests
germany struck a deal with russia to
allow the construction of a pipeline
directly between the two countries to
increase supplies of natural gas to
europe but nordstrom 2 is highly
controversial america for instance
thinks the pipeline will make europe
ever more dependent on russia for its
supply of energy
ukraine and poland also upset it means
them losing out on lucrative transit
fees for the gas that currently flows
through their countries
construction of the 11 billion pipeline
has already been finished america has
grudgingly agreed not to sanction the
german company involved
it struck a deal with germany to instead
sanction russia if it uses the energy as
a means to gain geopolitical leverage
so as one of the world's leading
economies the international community is
watching germany's election closely 16
years of leadership by angela merkel has
been stable
and enduringly popular but the direction
of this country has been defined by her
individual decisions rather than any
coherent political philosophy
the new chancellor will have to come up
with their own vision of germany's place
in the world